target practice at close range
for three years paulus kauskas has been
honing his skills at the paramilitary
lithuanian riflemen's union
membership has been growing by leaps and
bounds these days
russian state propaganda has set its
sights on lithuania
that means we could be next
the zuvalkeycap is especially critical
it's a corridor of land barely 65
kilometers wide between lithuania and
poland
it's the only land bridge from the
baltic republics to the rest of the nato
member states
fears are running high that moscow might
plan to sever this connection
the war in ukraine can even be felt in
the lithuanian border town vilcavichus
as more and more ukrainian refugees pour
in
red cross volunteers are collecting
groceries and clothing for them
irina
fled from the city of
in northeast ukraine
now she's helping other refugees
many of her friends and relatives stayed
in their homes in ukraine
that's what it's like for all ukrainians
living abroad now
irina is grateful for the great
solidarity the lithuanians have shown
the locals here share her outrage over
the russian invasion
is also enraged
but he's careful to distinguish between
the kremlin's policies and ordinary
russian citizens
i have russian customers who i stay in
touch with
i don't feel any personal hatred towards
them
more towards their state and the russian
state propaganda
but some russian civilians do feel the
effects of russia's invasion when they
take the train through lithuania to the
russian exclave kaliningrad
they're not allowed to set foot on
lithuanian territory
but from the trains windows they're
confronted with images of the war
and billboards with questions like
do they really want to support russian
president putin
the war in ukraine has sent a wake-up
call through all the baltic republics
lithuanian politicians warn
their country must arm itself against
the russian aggressor
i i would say we are
more patriotic but you should defend
your freedom and so on it's like
understanding of these fundamental
things we have just few years to prepare
ourselves that's why we need uh
more
nato presence in our region as a very
credible deterrent
hopes nato will station more troops in
lithuania
but if worse comes to worst he's
prepared to go to war even as a civilian
along with some fourteen thousand other
volunteers in the paramilitary union
it's hard to talk about the future we
live in difficult times and nobody knows
what tomorrow
so we need to focus on the here and now
take small steps
and reinforce our own country with
patriotism
many lithuanians are ready and on the
alert
especially near the zoovalky gap where
people are afraid they may suddenly find
themselves on the front line should
russia attack
you